Da! "Meeting, Dining, Dress Codes".
Ich muss ihm ja gewisse Dinge
in der Diplomatie beibringen.
Z.B.: Was tust du, wenn du willst,
dass die Leute nach Hause gehen?
"Es wird nur noch Wasser
zum Trinken angeboten."
* Sie lachen. *
"Die Gespräche
werden zum Abschluss gebracht."
"Respektieren Sie diese Zeichen
und verabschieden Sie sich!"
"Gäste, die überlang bleiben,
werden nirgends geschätzt."
* Feierliche Streichmusik *
* Dramatische Streichmusik *
Hold on! Are you at the Swiss club?
- C'est la, c'est la.
Este es mi machete,
Spickzettel, auf Deutsch.
Du bist Krisenmanager.
- Yes, are you here?
Yala, yala.
Diplomatie ist in der Schweiz
nicht besonders beliebt.
Man kennt uns nicht gut. Das ist
vielleicht auch unsere Schuld.
And a toast together.
(Ignazio Cassis) Auf Sie zählen wir
während der nächsten Jahrzehnte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte, orientalische Musik *
Call me if there is anything.
Für Samira geht es in Kairo wieder
los mit der Diplomatenausbildung.
Nach der Geburt ihrer Tochter Alani
machte sie fast sechs Monate Pause.
Ich freue mich.
Ja, ich habe Freude. Mal schauen,
wie der Tag auf der Botschaft wird.
* Sanfte, orientalische Musik *
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Wie geht's?
- Gut. Merci. Und dir? - Super.
Lief die Rede gestern noch gut?
Ja. Es war nicht schlecht.
Adrian Hauri
ist stellvertretender Missionschef.
Ihn muss Samira überzeugen,
wenn sie den Concours Diplomatique
erfolgreich abschliessen will.
Kairo ist eine Kultur und ein
Kontext, in dem es darauf ankommt,
persönliche Kontakte zu pflegen.
Das Netzwerk ist entscheidend.
Vieles geht mündlich
und über Kontakte,
die man mit Leuten direkt knüpft.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much.
Aber ist es grundsätzlich
ein Posten,
an dem man viele Einladungen erhält?
- Ja. Das ist ein grosser Aufwand:
die Organisation und das Hingehen.
Nach Feierabend verbringt man
viel Zeit an diesen Orten.
Man tauscht sich aus und kommt dann
spät nach Hause. Die Tage sind lang.
* Hahnenkrähen *
Frühmorgens in Myanmar.
Alexander ist aufgrund seiner
Diplomatenausbildung hierhergezogen
und lebt inzwischen
schon ein ganzes Jahr hier.
Seinen Lebensrhythmus
hat er angepasst.
Auf diesem Tennisplatz
haben wir kein Flutlicht.
Am Abend
ist er schwierig zu bespielen.
Um 17.30 Uhr geht die Sonne unter.
Tagsüber ist es zu heiss -
zwischen 30 und 35 °C.
Es ist gut, dass ich
mit Einheimischen spielen kann.
Und im Vergleich zur Schweiz
ist es viel günstiger,
hier Privatlektionen zu nehmen.
Ei!
* Sanft antreibende Musik *
Alexanders Freundin Simona
ist seinetwegen hergezogen.
Oh, yes. That's nice.
Die beiden haben sich
schon im Ausland kennengelernt.
Bei einem Austauschsemester
in Istanbul.
Jetzt sind sie gemeinsam
in Yangon in Myanmar.
This one.
* Er spricht birmanisch. *
* Sie antworten birmanisch. *
* Sie spricht birmanisch. *
1'800?
* Er spricht birmanisch. *
Yala, yala.
Myanmar war bis vor Kurzem
eine Militärdiktatur.
Für die meisten Leute ist es keine
grosse Gefahr, mit mir zu sprechen.
Aber sich in der Öffentlichkeit
auszudrücken, ist schwierig.
Viele haben immer noch Respekt
davor, dass der Staat durchgreift.
Angst, dass sie wegen irgendetwas
im Gefängnis landen.
Aber auch Angst
um ihren eigenen Ruf und davor,
dass andere nicht mehr
mit ihnen arbeiten möchten.
* "Tagesschau"-Signet *
Menschenrechtsaktivisten sprechen
von einem schleichenden Völkermord,
den Burma an den muslimischen
Rohingya im Land begehe.
Aber auch Aung San Suu Kyi wird
von den UNO-Experten kritisiert.
Sie habe ihre Position
nicht genutzt,
um die Gräueltaten zu verhindern.
Auch buddhistische Mönche heizen
den Hass gegen Muslime im Land an.
Besonders mächtig
ist die Bewegung Ma Ba Tha.
Alexander muss über diese Bewegung
einen politischen Bericht schreiben.
Er trifft einen Bekannten,
einen einheimischen Politologen.
Gegen
den buddhistischen Nationalismus
wird also offenbar
nicht genug gemacht.
Eine spannende Aussage für Alexander,
vielleicht wichtig für die Schweiz.
Sein Bericht kann Auswirkungen
auf die politischen Beziehungen
zwischen der Schweiz
und Myanmar haben.
Der politische Bericht
ist vielleicht eine Art Meilenstein.
Das Ganze wird eingeschätzt und neue
Aktivitäten können geplant werden.
Tschüss.
* Sanfte, orientalische Musik *
* Gespräche
werden von der Musik übertönt. *
Also, Adrian. Mach's gut!
- Alles Gute! - Danke für alles.
Schönen Abend.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
* Klopfen *
Hello!
Hello, my sweetie!
Hello.
Hello, cutie pie.
Hast du so lange geschlafen?
Das hast du so gut gemacht.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Mama.
Wie lief es denn bei dir?
- Super.
Sie hat uns schon zu verstehen
gegeben, dass sie Mama vermisst.
Wir waren froh,
dass wir zu zweit waren.
Für jemanden alleine wäre es
streng gewesen - für den ersten Tag.
Hast du ihre Haare gepackt?
* Beschwingte Musik *
In seiner Diplomatenausbildung
im Senegal
hat Jean-Baptiste
v.a. mit dem Thema Wasser zu tun.
Wasser ist ein Schwerpunkt in der
Schweizer Entwicklungszusammenarbeit.
Es gibt Länder, die Wasser haben.
Und es gibt Länder,
die Wasser brauchen.
Das führt zu gewissen Spannungen
auf der Welt.
Aber hier in Westafrika
haben wir ein Beispiel von Ländern,
die sich gut verstanden haben.
Hier führt eine intelligente Teilung
von Wasserressourcen zu Stabilität.
Die Idee der Schweiz war,
die Leute aus Zentralasien
nach Westafrika zu bringen,
damit sie
miteinander diskutieren können.
So entstehen vielleicht,
vielleicht auch nicht,
gute Lösungen und Gelegenheiten.
Die Schweiz erhält eine sehr gute
Visibilität in dieser Konstellation,
ohne viel zu tun -
einfach als Vermittler.
Es ist nicht blauäugig,
wenn man Menschenrechte, Frieden
und Gleichgewicht auf der Welt
und in der Umwelt verteidigt.
Das ist zuerst v.a.
im Interesse unseres Landes.
Natürlich gibt es auch
eine humanistische Komponente.
Wir sind froh und stolz, dass sich
die jungen Leute dafür einsetzen.
Aber es geht auch um die
Interessensvertretung eines Landes,
das ein Interesse daran hat,
dass die Welt friedlich,
umweltfreundlich, gut organisiert
und demokratisch ist.
Jean-Baptiste
ist mit der Botschafterin unterwegs.
Sie haben heute ein wichtiges Treffen
zum Thema Wasser.
Kurz bevor wir aus der Botschaft
weg sind, habe ich erfahren ...
Ich muss nochmals nachschauen.
Jemand kommt nicht.
Wenn wir bei mir zu Hause ankommen,
ist es das Erste,
was wir tun werden:
die Tischordnung rearrangieren.
Darf ich dir zuschauen,
wie du das machst?
Natürlich.
- Davon habe ich keine Ahnung.
Darum bist du im Stage.
- Ja, klar.
Dann möchte ich dir
eine kleine Arbeit geben.
Wenn die Gäste kommen,
sagst du den Gästen:
"Bitte, Frau Soundso,
das ist Ihr Platz."
Leite sie an den Platz!
- Okay.
Sie sind auf dem Weg in die Residenz
der Schweizer Botschaft.
Zwei Wasserexperten aus der Schweiz
sind angereist.
On a encore un programme.
Je fais ca. Stager.
- Monsieur Duss.
Il y a encore un programme
mis a jour.
Je ne sais pas exactement
ce qu'ils ont change.
Die Wasserspezialisten
aus der Schweiz sollen heute Abend
Experten im Senegal kennenlernen.
Hallo!
Mein Mann, Waldemar Krupski.
Er kommt offenbar direkt vom Sport.
Genau.
Ich möchte dich bitten,
das hier zu falten.
Es ist nicht
auf beiden Seiten beschriftet.
Ich weiss, wie ich heisse.
Was ist das hier?
- Das Menü.
Ich ziehe mich rasch um.
Ist das gut?
Ja, gut.
- Merci.
* Räuspern *
Der Stagiaire macht sich jetzt
an die Tischordnung.
Kannst du das aufhängen?
Die müssten so hängen.
Wieso habt ihr die weggenommen?
Dorthin!
Kannst du sie schnell festmachen?
Der erste Gast ist schon da.
Hi. How are you?
Best wishes. - Good to see you.
- I know. Finally we get together.
Bonsoir, Madame.
- Jean-Baptiste Deleze.
Merci.
Apero im Garten -
das ist harte Arbeit.
An solchen Anlässen
werden wichtige Themen besprochen.
Und manchmal
gibt's auch Überraschungen.
Jean-Baptiste reagiert sofort.
C'est juste comme-ca?
- Oui.
Je vous en prie.
Ici.
- Merci. - S'il vous plait.
Madame Garchage.
S'il vous plait.
- Merci.
Asseyez-vous, s'il vous plait.
Beim Abendessen
wird weitergearbeitet.
Heute versuchen
Vertreter aus der Schweiz,
wichtige Leute aus dem Senegal
für ein Projekt zu gewinnen.
Die Schweiz will,
dass asiatische Staaten
von Westafrika lernen können, wie man
mit der Ressource Wasser umgeht,
damit keine Konflikte entstehen.
Voila.
Bon.
Die Schweizer Botschaft in Kairo
hat zu einem Konzert
von Schweizer Musikern eingeladen.
Ce soir nous avons le plaisir
d'avoir Marc Aymon.
# Tu mets la barre haut.
(Alle) # Tu mets la barre haut.
Bei kulturellen Events
ist es sehr spannend,
ein Bild der Schweiz zu vermitteln.
Und auch Werte zu kommunizieren,
die unserem Land wichtig sind.
Bonsoir.
Gastgeber ist, wie immer an solchen
Anlässen, der Botschafter vor Ort.
There is my card.
Thank you so much.
Der Aufbau eines Netzwerks ist für
einen solchen Job extrem wichtig.
Das mache ich sehr gerne.
Dafür muss ich da sein,
präsent sein, Leute treffen.
Wenn ich den Botschafter
hier sehe ...
Er hat fast täglich
abends noch Empfänge.
Es ist am Ende
ein grosses Engagement.
Man muss auch bereit sein,
auf vieles zu verzichten.
Mit einer einjährigen Tochter
wäre ich noch nicht dazu bereit.
Aber wer weiss,
wie sich das in Zukunft entwickelt.
Vielleicht kann man in Zukunft
auch mal Jobsharing machen.
* Gefühlvolle Schlussklänge *
* Applaus *
Alexander
hat seinen politischen Bericht
über die aktuelle Situation
in Myanmar fertig geschrieben.
Dieser geht
an die Zentrale des EDA in Bern.
Es sind
etwas weniger als fünf Seiten.
Aber ich glaube, das ist gut so.
Es ist kondensiert.
Das ist auch der Anspruch
des neuen Departementvorstehers:
Es muss kompakt sein und
auf wenigen Seiten zusammengefasst.
* Klopfen *
Agnes, darf ich dich kurz stören?
Das ist der politische Bericht,
wie er im Moment ist.
Fertig? Super.
- So weit fertig.
Aber ich möchte wissen,
was du darüber denkst.
Danke, Alex.
Es muss eine Aussage haben. Es muss
starke analytische Elemente haben.
Der wichtige Teil am Ende,
der sich von einem akademischen
Kurzpapier unterscheidet,
ist das, was es
für die Schweizer Politik bedeutet.
Alexander hat lange an diesem
politischen Bericht gearbeitet.
Er muss überzeugen.
Denn auch diese Arbeit
entscheidet darüber,
ob er
die Diplomatenausbildung besteht.
In Yangon
wohnt er mit seiner Freundin Simona
in einer Vierzimmerwohnung.
Hello.
- Hello.
In einer Weinhandlung in Myanmar
hat Simona einen Job gefunden.
Etwas Neues
für die studierte Soziologin.
* Drollige Musik *
Mir wurde verboten, zu kochen.
Ich weiss nicht, woran das liegt.
Simona musste wegen Alexanders Job
ganz neu anfangen.
Sie musste sich von Anfang an
nicht nur auf mich verlassen.
Sie ging selbst raus,
machte ihr Ding,
fand relativ schnell
eine Betätigung im Weinshop.
Sie hat Hobbys gefunden.
Das hat Druck von mir genommen.
So muss ich nicht
jeden Abend denken:
"Nein, Simona ist zu Hause
und wartet auf mich."
Wenn Alexander
die Diplomatenausbildung besteht,
gehört es zu seinem Leben,
dass er alle vier Jahre in ein
neues Land kommt und dort arbeitet.
* Gemütlicher Song *
Schon seit einem Jahr
ist Cristina jetzt in New York.
Ich merke, dass es mir guttut,
wenn ich mal
einen Nachmittag oder Abend lang
zu Hause bin,
nähe oder ein Buch lese.
Das brauche ich auch -
diese ruhige Zeit.
Das Leben in der Diplomatie
kann auch einsam sein.
Seit eineinhalb Jahren
ist Cristina Tante.
Aber das Kind
ihrer Zwillingsschwester
sieht sie nicht richtig aufwachsen.
Hallo.
Hallo, Leonie.
- Ja, wer ist denn da?
Was hast du heute gemacht?
- Wir hatten vorher einen Apero.
Sie hat drei Oliven gegessen.
Und einen gegrillten Pilz.
- Okay.
Und was hast du gemacht?
Die Russen
haben die Sprache eingereicht.
Jetzt braucht man Zeit,
um zu diskutieren, ob man das will.
* Leonie weint. *
Und am Sonntag ... Oh, Leonie.
Was machen sie mit dir?
So, jetzt ist der Nuggi wieder ...
Ja.
- Ja.
Gut, gut. - Dann ist
bei euch schon bald Abend.
Ja, genau.
Also. Tschau!
- Tschau.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ich vermisse sie schon ein wenig.
Auch Leonie.
Sie entwickelt sich schnell
und wächst.
Und ich bekomme das
nur aus der Distanz mit.
Daher ...
Es ist wichtig für mich,
dass wir regelmässig telefonieren.
Jean-Baptiste arbeitet
immer wieder auch am Wochenende.
Wenn er mal frei hat, so wie heute,
kocht er sich
für die ganze Woche vor.
Das ist ein super Topf.
Er kocht den besten Couscous.
Kurz vor Senegal
haben sich Jean-Baptiste
und seine Partnerin getrennt.
So war er von Anfang an
auf sich alleine gestellt.
Was mir sehr dabei geholfen hat,
mich daheim oder wohlzufühlen,
ist die Arbeit.
Die Arbeit
ist ein grosser Integrationsfaktor.
Man ist hier für die Arbeit.
Man findet sehr schnell
seine Familie.
Kollegen von der Botschaft
oder von anderen Botschaften.
Das hilft.
Ich weiss: Wenn ich
in einer Beziehung sein möchte,
wird es ein riesiges Thema sein.
Denn dein Job
bestimmt die Geografie
für die andere Person.
Es ist ein bisschen traurig,
das zu sagen.
Aber ich merke die Vorteile
des Single-Daseins.
Und das ist ...
Das ist so.
Was hast du geholt? - Ich dachte,
ich hätte einen Pullover dabei.
Aber den habe ich
wohl zu Hause gelassen.
Und was zu trinken?
Für Jonas und Katrin
ist heute ein wichtiger Tag.
Katrin hat ein Konzert
an einem Festival.
Hast du noch eine Tasche?
- Ja. Meine Sachen sind dort.
Ich hole etwas zu trinken.
- Ja.
In diesem Hotel
treffen sich die Musiker.
Von hier aus
bringt sie ein Fahrer zum Konzert,
das ausserhalb von Buenos Aires
stattfindet.
In Paradero.
Oh, wow.
- Agua. - Danke schön.
Sehr gut. Agua.
I'm from Germany.
Für Katrin war es nicht einfach, ihr
eigenes Berufsleben zurückzustellen.
Umso wichtiger, dass sie heute Abend
auf der Bühne stehen kann.
Mir bedeutet das unheimlich viel.
Ich wollte das immer.
Das ist mein Traum.
Dabei zu sein mit etwas,
was ich wirklich liebe!
Schau noch kurz nach,
damit du alles hast.
Meine Schuhe,
mein Kleid, meine CDs ...
Eine Banane habe ich auch.
- Okay.
Gute Fahrt.
- Danke.
Wir sehen uns dort.
- Wir sehen uns dort.
Und wenn was ist, einfach anrufen!
- Ich habe das Handy dabei.
Jonas will nochmals nach Hause,
bevor er selbst ans Konzert fährt.
Aber es wird etwas kompliziert.
* Drollige Musik *
Alles okay?
Okay. Und wie sieht es aus?
Ja. Sie sind offenbar noch nicht
vom Treffpunkt in Buenos Aires
abgefahren.
Katrins Fahrer ist nicht gekommen.
Darum soll Jonas einspringen.
Eigentlich.
Hallo?
Ah, wunderbar. Okay.
Gut. Dann gehen wir direkt.
Okay. Das Problem hat sich gelöst.
Oder auch nicht.
Ja, hallo.
Okay. Ich muss da kurz rausfahren.
Moment.
* Drollige Musik *
Ja, ja.
Was möchtest du,
was wir jetzt machen?
Ich komme dich mal abholen. Tschüss.
Wo bist du jetzt?
* Hupen *
Okay. Dann gehen wir jetzt auch.
Okay. Ist ja blöd.
Okay. Gut. Ja. Tschüss.
Sie ist soeben abgefahren.
Der Fahrer ist doch noch gekommen.
* Er lacht. *
Alexander bekommt heute das Feedback
für seinen politischen Bericht.
Agnes.
- Hallo. Setz dich mal!
Also. Ich habe den Bericht gelesen.
Ich finde ihn wirklich sehr gut.
Es ist ... alles drin.
Es ist sehr informativ. Und
es schildert das ganze Thema gut.
Allgemein
ist er noch ein bisschen zu lang.
Auch die Zusammenfassung am Anfang.
- Okay.
Sie ist ein bisschen zu detailliert.
- Ja.
Das Bild vom schlafenden Riesen,
das du als Titel genommen hast ...
Ich habe mich gefragt, ob es
wirklich ein schlafender Riese ist.
Ma Ba Tha ist eigentlich
unter der Oberfläche sehr aktiv.
Vielleicht
ist das auch eine Sprachsache.
Du hast recht. Das mit dem Titel
habe ich mir auch zweimal überlegt.
Und auch,
wie ich das erläutern soll.
Ähm ...
Ich glaube, es macht Sinn,
das noch etwas zu präzisieren.
Ja. Was hatte ich noch?
Ich glaube, das ist schon alles.
Perfekt.
Vielen Dank für das Feedback.
Es sind teilweise Fragen,
die ich mir im Prozess
auch selbst gestellt habe.
Okay. Super. - Danke vielmals.
- Danke für das Feedback.
Bis später.
- Bis später.
Die Meinung seiner Chefin
ist für Alexander wichtig.
Solche Berichte muss er
vielleicht bald öfter schreiben.
Ähm ... Ich glaube ...
... den Mut zu haben,
kurz und bündig zu schreiben.
Es muss nicht immer
ein literarisches Kunstwerk sein.
Informationen
müssen vermittelt werden.
Das kann man bei mir
noch vereinfachen.
Es war definitiv ein Privileg,
die letzten 15 Monate hier zu sein.
Es ist ein enorm spannendes Land.
Ein kompliziertes Land.
Es ist nicht einfach zu verstehen.
Es bräuchte mehr als 15 Monate,
um da reinzukommen.
Darum bleibt es für mich
enorm faszinierend.
* Südamerikanische Folkloremusik *
Jonas hat es fast geschafft.
Er ist in Paradero angekommen.
Hier hat Katrin
schon bald ihren Auftritt.
Katrin spielt sich noch ein.
Es ist so kalt. Mir ist so kalt,
ich spüre meine Hände nicht.
Okay.
Es ist so kalt.
Hace mucho frio.
- Hace frio? - Oh, ja.
Das ist
auch ein Zeichen von Nervosität.
Aber mir ist
jetzt auch wirklich kalt.
Ich wärme meine Hände
hier am Nacken.
So. Noch so einen warmen Mate-Tee.
Eine solche Jacke
würde ich jetzt auch gerne haben.
Ich gebe sie dir. - Nein.
- Du gehst ja noch nicht rein.
Es ist nicht gut,
jetzt warm zu haben,
und dann falle ich
in dieses kalte Loch.
Ich kenne das. Ich muss da jetzt
einfach frierend durch. - Okay.
Ja.
Das Konzert ist nicht nur für Katrin,
sondern auch für Jonas wichtig.
Für mich ist wichtig, dass jeder
von uns eine eigene Leidenschaft hat
Bei Katrin ist das
die klassische Gitarre.
* Applaus *
* Sanfte, perlende Gitarrenmusik *
Was wir hier hatten,
können wir überall aufbauen.
Ich bin in der Diplomatie tätig,
Katrin verfolgt
ihre Leidenschaft für die Musik.
Das könnte auch
an anderen Orten klappen.
* Hupen *
Ja. Ihnen hat es super gefallen.
Die haben alle 100-mal gesagt,
wie gut es ihnen gefallen hat.
Die grosse Abschlussprüfung für Jonas
in der nächsten Folge
von "Die jungen Diplomaten".